The purpose of Kendo is to respond to the mandate of the people with confidence and pride even if it hits the police business
[Music]
My name is Mitsuru Hamasaki
Originally  I'm a police officer. I'm Kendo Norishi Hachidan. I'm
trying to teach young people. I've been
learning kendo for 59 years. In
Japanese martial arts, prefectural roads have a bamboo sword.
Keys were made and
they were gradually
used in battles, etc.
Kendo tools
were not developed and kendo
training became popular.
[Music]
When I entered the police, I chose kendo and kendo.
Food
I think it's something that can stand a
little  That technical
thing is important, but I think that spiritual thing is also very important.
I think it is necessary to
come  Masu
[Music]